une carrière professionnelle c'est une
succession d'événements inattendus comme
certains
vous j'ai fait un ut
génie des matériaux ici je me faisais
les matériaux j'ai trouvé du boulot
parce qu'il y en a partout il y en a
dans l'automobile y en a dans le bois il
y en a dans les skis le sport etc
donc j'ai bien trouvé un métier qui va
me corresponde c'est ça s'est plutôt
bien passé l'ambiance était sympa j'ai
eu des bons des bons résultats
alors j'ai continué j'ai continué mes
études
et puis je suis rentrée à l'école des
mines de nancy en section pour les
matériaux et la gestion de production
gestion de production je suis la
production a partout et on a pour
fabriquer des voitures pour fabriquer
des chaises du matériel de sport
donc je me suis dit je vais bien trouver
du travail avec ça s'était plutôt
intéressante des challengers comprendre
comment on faisait un produit de a à z
d'organiser la production avec les
problèmes de qualité etc
au fur et à mesure
dès l'école vous posez des questions
qu'est ce que je vais faire
alors vous rencontrez toujours des
anciens qui vous disent moi je travaille
chez peugeot je travaille chez hertz et
l'orge fait si je fais ça et puis vous
avez quelques collègues qui vous disent
ben moi je veux travailler dans le
laboratoire d'art c'est l'or parce que
je fais de la recherche sur l'acier
inoxydable
hu a aussi hyper précis et moi j' avais
aucune idée ça vous met un petit peu un
petit peu la pression
alors au fur et à mesure de ces trois
années
je me suis dit je vais travailler dans
l'automobile sur une chaîne de montage
je vais gérer une équipe on va fabriquer
des voitures organisé gagner du temps
améliorer la qualité etc
ouais pourquoi pas ou alors je me suis
dit j'ai travaillé dans la métallurgie
c'est assez assez grandiose il ya du
métal en fusion on fabrique des bars des
tubes
ça sert à construire des ponts etc on se
rend utile
donc voila vous imaginez la suite mais
en fait ça s'est pas vraiment passé
comme ça mon premier métier ça a été ça
enfin pas vraiment ça a été de fabriquer
ce sac voilà c'était bien loin de
l'automobile est bien loin de là de la
métallurgie
mon premier métier c'était une manager
une équipe pour fabriquer un sac à main
pour lui tant j'avais une trentaine de
personnes que des femmes
j'avais 23 ans il avait tout plus de 35
ans mais au final c'était une super
expérience
j'ai appris beaucoup enfin elles m'ont
fait apprendre beaucoup en fait j'ai
beaucoup appris grâce à elle j'ai appris
le management j'ai appris bien sûr la
qualité
j'ai appris aussi ce que c'était le lean
manufacturing tous et toutes ces notions
là c'était une très bonne une très bonne
expérience
et puis après toujours la même boîte on
m'a envoyée en roumanie en roumanie je
savais pas vraiment où c'était charles x
et en europe de l'est mais
visualisez pas trop géographiquement ou
ça se trouvait et là j'ai participé avec
une équipe pour monter une entreprise
toujours pourvus ton c'est super
intéressant mais j'ai appris plein de
choses j'ai appris la langue parce que
vous travaillez des gens vous parlez pas
la même langue et ne parlent pas la même
langue que vous donc pour se comprendre
c'est un petit peu compliqué et puis ils
ont pas les mêmes la même culture
mais j'ai appris énormément énormément
sur les autres personnes sur les autres
cultures et travailler travailler en
équipe
ensuite j'ai fabriqué des bracelets
montres alors bracelet montre ça n'a
rien à voir encore avec l'automobile la
métallurgie je cherche toujours mais il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de lien en
fait ça paraît simple à faire des
bracelets montres mais en fait c'est
très compliqué hélas pour le groupe
richemont
ben on m'a donné mission de créer un
atelier on est parti de rien c'était un
peu en mode en mode start up
donc il fallait être innovant met au
point un process former des gens j'ai
appris à prendre des décisions très
rapidement parce qu'il y avait des
commandes qui arrivait et puis il
fallait les livrets et puis on était
dans une super super dynamique et puis
ça marchait ça marchait plutôt bien et
puis au bout d'un moment je me disais
dans cet atelier qu'est ce que je vais
faire la route mais pas me paraissait
longue la production c'est un moment
donné pour moi c'était recevoir des
commandes fabriquer et puis livrés alors
bien sûr gérer des problèmes qualité
gérer des problèmes de management mais
je voyais pas là la sortie et je n'avais
plus la motivation
alors je me suis un petit peu posé
chacun ses techniques pour pour
réfléchir et puis je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qui me plaît plus ce qui me
plaisait plus c'était d'être enfermé
dans cet atelier là tout le temps être
avec les mêmes personnes et de pas avoir
de contact avec
d'autres gens d'autres projets d'autres
secteurs secteur d'activité ce que
j'avais envie de faire c'était justement
d'aller au delà de la production voir
d'autres choses je me suis rendu compte
que pour faire tourner une entreprise y
avait pas que la production même si
c'est l'essence même d'une entreprise
mais y'a plein de services qui sont
utiles et qui servent également à
l'entreprise
et puis peut-être avec l'âge avec le
fait d'avoir aussi des enfants on se dit
ça serait peut-être mieux aussi de
travailler plus convenablement de
produire d'une autre façon alors je suis
arrivé dans un service qui s'appelle le
sourcing responsable responsible
sourcing alors peut-être ça vous parle
pas en quoi ça consiste
ça consiste à s'assurer qu'avec les gens
avec qui on travaille
il respecte notre code notre code
éthique et puis s'assurer que tout est
respecté et qu'il n'y a pas de risque
aussi pour nous mais pour l'entreprise
en terme d'image en termes de réputation
le but c'est d'éviter entre autres tout
ça le monde a changé
et puis les entreprises des fois il faut
on va dire des bêtises pourquoi parce
qu' on cherche à aller vite on cherche
bien sûr à gagner de l'argent mais au
final elles prennent des décisions qui
nous paraissent complètement un problème
et si nous on avait été seul on n'aurait
jamais pris cette décision là et du coup
ce qui est intéressant c'est petit à
petit de faire changer l'entreprise en
étant au sein de cette entreprise là
alors sur quoi on sur quoi on travaille
on travaille sur l'amélioration des
conditions de travail pour pour les
personnes on travaille sur également
l'environnement ou bien sur le bien-être
animal parce que je m'occupe entre
autres de tout ce qui est clair vous
avez compris j'ai eu un passé un petit
peu lié à ce matériau la lier liée au
cuir
comment on procède c'est souvent la même
les mêmes opérations
on investigue une supply chain on essaie
de comprendre comment ça marche
il ya deux semaines j'étais avec des
fermiers américains
c'est les gens qui élèvent des
alligators et puis en même temps j'étais
avec des chimistes qui font des
et des essais dans un laboratoire c'est
juste deux mondes qui sont complètement
différent en fait voilà donc ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'arriver à faire le
lien avec ces avec ces deux mondes là
une fois qu'on a compris comment ça
fonctionnait on se dit mais c'est quoi
nos objectifs sur sur cette supply chain
qu'est ce qu'on veut comme critère et
qu'est ce qui est important pour nous et
puis qu'est ce qui est important bien
sûr pour l'entreprise mais aussi si en
tant que bon père de famille qu'est ce
qu'on a envie de mettre en place pour
les générations futures
et puis pour pour nos enfants une fois
qu'on a décidé ça c'est comment on
s'assure que tout le monde le fait
comment on contrôle et puis il ya une
certaine satisfaction à voir que les
gens évoluent et qu'on arrive à faire
progresser tous tous nos fournisseurs
voilà ça sert en gros que c'est mon
travail et c'est maintenant c'est ce qui
me plaît le plus même si j'ai
complètement changé je regrette pas du
tout d'avoir d'avoir changé
ce que je voudrais que vous reteniez
c'est le premier point c'est que les
entreprises changent de plus en plus il
ya des nouveaux métiers qui arrive celui
là en est un il n'existait pas il ya
il ya dix ans ça n'existait pas le
deuxième le deuxième point c'est pas
parce que vous avez fait une formation
vous allez travailler tout le temps dans
ce domaine là moi j'ai fait une
formation aux matériaux dans la
plasturgie la métallurgie
bien sûr ça m'a servi parce que ça m'a
formé mais j'ai jamais utilisé
finalement ces compétences là le
troisième point ce cas important et
c'est peut-être le plus important c'est
rester curieux même à votre poste
écouter tout ce qui se passe autour de
vous écouter tous les services qui sont
en lien avec vous tous les projets et
faites preuve de curiosité c'est surtout
ça qui est important maintenant dans
notre dans notre monde et c'est ça qui
va vous permettre d'évoluer
et puis le dernier conseil que je peux
vous donner c'est surtout une phrase et
surtout n'hésitez pas à sortir du cadre
parce que de plus en plus dans nos
entreprises on a besoin de gens
justement qui sortent du cadre et qui
nous apportent ces choses là
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]